today on the matt well show our big tech
overlords have unveiled a new ritual for
us apparently now you're supposed to
introduce yourself with name pronouns
and also race it's the cutting edge of
wokeness we'll talk about that today
also the prosecution's case completely
collapses in the kyle rittenhouse trial
and the left has a good laugh over
inflation at the grocery store plus a
teacher explains what democrats really
mean when they say that critical race
theory isn't taught in schools they're
lying okay not to not to spoil the
ending and finally dave portnoy of
barstool sports gets the me too
treatment we'll talk about all that and
more today on the matt wells show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so you thought maybe that our
civilization would burn into ashes or
explode like
fireworks you thought we'd be we would
be brought trembling under the boot heel
of some violent dictator but american
society won't be blessed with such a
dramatic ending as that the last thing
we will see before it all goes dark is
the smiling face of a corporate
marketing executive in a pantsuit
telling us her pronouns i mean there are
there are elements of 1984 thrown into
what we're experiencing right now but
we're actually living in a brave new
world exhibit a
uh microsoft's virtual marketing
conference called ignite 2021
just concluded its three-day run now
typically the purpose of this type of
event is to unveil new and upcoming
products
get consumers excited about all the
wonderful and cutting edge opportunities
for consumption that microsoft will
provide in the year ahead the goal as
always is to chip away at flesh and
blood human existence little by little
until our lives have been entirely
subsumed by the screen
microsoft and its competitors
stand basically at the entrance to the
black hole beckoning us to enter and be
absorbed by it this this process has
become increasingly literal as big tech
moves
uh towards our utopian metaverse future
now recently mark zuckerberg
gave birth to
meta platforms incorporated which is now
the parent company of facebook instagram
and subsidiaries he's not you know he's
not talking about facebook anymore it's
meta platforms that's the new company
zuckerberg concerned that although we
spend 10 hours a day staring at our
screen we still haven't quite invested
enough of ourselves into it he wants to
turn social media into a virtual reality
metaverse experience
soon we'll be able to
enter into the internet
swapping our bloated fleshy carcasses
for cartoon avatars and perhaps never
returning to the real world again
you know zuckerberg watched the matrix
and mistook it for a how-to manual
apparently and microsoft isn't far
behind the star attraction of the ignite
2021 conference was its new mesh
software its first foray into the the
metaverse not quite as fancy as
zuckerberg's version but it will allow
you to attend virtual work meetings as
an avatar if for some reason you want to
there are also 3d and virtual reality
components to it as well down the line
microsoft hopes through mesh that you'll
be able to mesh with cyberspace become
one with it
and finally lose whatever pieces of your
unique individual self still remain but
ignite 2021 wasn't just a spectacle of
new technology it was also an
opportunity to roll out groundbreaking
state-of-the-art wokeness
microsoft senior program manager allison
wines kicked things off with a religious
ritual that has become somewhat familiar
on sort of the fringes of the far left
cult but had yet to make its way into
mainstream corporate uh into the
mainstream corporate world until now
this is called a land acknowledgment
and uh here's what it sounds like listen
hello and welcome to microsoft ignite
we've got a big day ahead and lots in
store for you
first we want to acknowledge that the
land where the microsoft campus is
situated was traditionally occupied by
the sammamish the duwamish the
snoqualmie the sukwamish the muckleshoot
the snohomish the tulalip and other
coast salish peoples since time
immemorial a people that are still here
continuing to honor and bring to light
their ancient heritage
my name is alison wines i'm a senior
program manager in our developer tools
division i'm an asian white female with
dark brown hair wearing a red sleeveless
top
and i'm seth juarez program manager in
the ai platform group i'm a tall
hispanic male wearing a blue shirt khaki
pants today we kick off two days of
learning more about the latest solutions
exploring how these key innovations can
empower you to do great things and
connecting with peers from around the
world
it's i mean truly
the most embarrassing i didn't think it
could be topped but this is the most
embarrassing and cringy thing
that we've seen from microsoft since
their uh windows 95 rollout which if you
never can we just play a quick clip of
that this was the windows 95 any
opportunity to play this for a minute
this some somehow what you just saw is
more embarrassing than this their
windows 95 roll out
of uh
[Music]
there's a lot of dad dancing going on up
there way too much of it looks like
they're having some sort of medical
emergency
and there's bill gates
my god
i actually cannot i can't keep watching
turn this off okay that's as much of
that as i can see
actually okay
what we just saw with allison wines was
not quite as embarrassing but almost
they almost got there
now i mean but how could any marketing
conference come commence without first
paying homage to the honorable
muckleshoot people all 14 of them
obviously have to start with that
and this is empty posturing of course
you'll note how microsoft acknowledges
that the land allegedly belongs to these
tribes and yet chooses to still remain
on that land this is like stealing
somebody's car you know you go and steal
your neighbor bill smith's car and you
make up for it by beating your chest and
chanting i acknowledge that this car
belongs to bill smith every time you you
know get into it
the difference is that taking someone's
car is clear and direct theft
whereas the western acquisition of land
land that the tribes had already been
killing each other over for centuries
before the white man arrived is not
theft it's conquest and there's a
difference
but from microsoft's professed
perspective the car analogy holds up so
it doesn't make any sense
why then do they bother with the land
acknowledgement
i mean it's it's virtue signaling yes
but what is the alleged virtue being
signaled here
the virtue is white guilt white
groveling white abnegation
the problem with virtue signaling
it's it's not really the signaling part
but the nature of the supposed virtue
that is being signaled
speaking of which you no doubt notice
that she also after doing the landing
acknowledgement she also identified
herself by her race white asian whatever
that's supposed to mean and other
physical descriptions this is a verified
thing now this is what they're doing
or at least our big tech overlords want
it to be a thing throughout the whole
conference apparently speakers did
exactly this they identified themselves
not only by pronouns but also by their
race and other qualifiers as well let's
uh let's watch a little bit more of that
hello everyone i'm natalie godilla i'm a
caucasian woman with long blonde hair
and i go by she her i'm a product
marketing lead here at microsoft and
co-host of the podcast security unlocked
with this guy yes that would be me hello
everyone i'm nick fillingham i'm a
caucasian man with glasses and a beard i
go by he him and i'm a security
evangelist here at microsoft hello
everyone i'm so glad to be here with you
with you all here i'm a woman of indian
descent i have brown hair brown eyes and
i'm wearing some uh killer five inch
heels sure
what
first of all what is a security
evangelist
um also how do you not mention that you
have a mohawk i mean you're describing
your hair and your physical features
the guy this is a middle-aged you know
45-year-old man with a mohawk and he
doesn't think to mention that that's i
think that's the most relevant piece of
information
i mean if i'm if i'm a middle-aged man
with a mohawk
leaves that out of it
that would be like if you if you had
three arms
and the only thing you said about
yourself is i'm wearing a white shirt
and i have brown hair
now the stated reason for this ritual is
that it's meant to help those who are
visually impaired
but considering that a fair number of
blind people have been blind from birth
you have to wonder how much help you're
really giving them by identifying your
hair color
what does color mean to them
and besides is it necessary to frame
your conversation in such a bizarre
and intrusive way in order to satisfy a
tiny minority almost none of whom
actually asked for this to begin with
well yes that is indeed the leftist way
and here's another question
why is race relevant anyway
why do people need to know
that information about the speaker in
the first place
even if we're going to introduce
ourselves with physical descriptions for
the benefit of the tiny percentage of
people who can't see it for themselves
why should our skin color be the first
thing we mentioned
i mean should people on the radio be
doing this too should the voiceover guy
in a serial commercial start by
identifying his race i'm a white man
with brown hair he him i'm heterosexual
please buy cheerios
that is indeed where we're headed
and we will be pushed there by people
like this at microsoft and facebook
the left continues of course to fashion
itself as as the resistance as
counterculture
but it not only has the corporate world
on its side it's not just that the
corporate world is on its side the
corporate world is perhaps its primary
vehicle
for getting even its most radical
concepts and ideas into the mainstream
second only maybe to the education
system
and considering that big tech is also in
the process of literally fashioning a
new reality for us to live in that wants
us to take us wants to take us out of
the universe and put us into the
metaverse
um i think that fact should especially
concern us
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
during the cobia 19 era tech support
scams have surged to the top of the list
of internet scam threats tech support
scams are attacks that rely on fear
uncertainty and doubt they're designed
to trick you into believing something is
wrong and they seek to steal your
personal information tap your bank
account or install danger software on
your device just one of the many threats
you face on the internet a lot of bad a
lot of bad actors out there
and that's why it's so important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives every day
because every day we do put our
information at risk on the internet in
an instant a cyber criminal could harm
what's yours your finances your credit
that's why it's so good that there's
lifelock lifelock helps detect a wide
range of a wide range of threats like
for example if your information is for
sale on the dark web things that
you wouldn't see if you were monitoring
your credit score or monitoring your
bank account you're not going to know
about many of the other threats that are
out there and if something does happen
and your threat is kind and your
identity is compromised well lifelock
has identity restoration specialists on
staff who can help you with that as well
if they detect your information they
will send you an alert nobody can
prevent all identity theft or monitor
all transactions at all businesses but
you can keep what's yours with lifelock
identity theft protection join now and
save 25
off your first year by going to
lifelock.com welsh that's lifelock.com
walls for 25 off
uh you know i'm still a little bit uh
shaken and overcoming some trauma that i
experienced last night
um
[Music]
and there there are moments in life
where you learn lessons and you learn
the hard ways hard ways sometimes
and that happened to me last night i was
you know it was with my wife we're in
the kitchen
just talking
having a nice conversation as you do in
the kitchen
i pulled out
um my bottle of sam houston 15-year
bourbon which is uh it's premium bourbon
it's very very good
not quite good enough to justify the
expense i'll say that like it's a it's a
really good b plus a minus bourbon
uh but it had a price point of an a plus
bourbon and it wasn't quite but still
it's still very good that's that's the
point you know premium really good burp
and um
and you know they they make a batch of
like six bottles right and so it's also
hard to find and i was and i was proud
of it and i was you know i poured some
and then i said to my wife do you want
you want
you want some of this you want to try
some of this it's very generous on my
part to begin with that i'm that i'm
going to share it
and she was drinking some tea at the
time
but she said oh yeah sure pour me a
little bit
and i did and i handed it to her
and she took that glass
and dumped it into the tee
and i stood there
i i this is a moment where i could say
lit i was literally shaking
i i couldn't believe what i just
witnessed in front of my own eyes
this would be like if we were
at an art museum looking at the mona
lisa and my wife pulled out crayons and
started coloring over top of it
and i said what what how why would you
do that what are you doing
you don't put that in tea
she said oh i wanted to make a hot toddy
i said you want to make a hot toddy let
me you make all the hot toddies i'll go
out and buy you some evan williams
bourbon for 22 dollars
okay that's that's what they call a rail
bourbon you go you go all the way to the
bottom rung and that's where you pull
out the stuff to make your hot toddies
this is a top rung bourbon you don't do
that
and they know what she did
she started laughing
it's like i married the joker okay this
this
chaos had been brought into our home
i'm psychologically i'm i'm in
psychological and emotional turmoil and
she's laughing about it
literally unbelievable this is this is
like it's like if i
i you know i can't even think of a
computer it's like you bring home a 100
cut of of
sirloin and you know then and then and
then chop it into pieces and cook it
well done and serve it in a fajita
now now i can't i can't bring i can't
bring fancy bourbon into the house
that's for sure
what if i had like a bottle of papi 23
that for some reason i spent 5 000 on
and then i come home
and the whole bottle's sitting there on
the counter empty
and my wife says oh i made a bourbon
bundt cake
you know people and and i did put this
on twitter of course to shame her
publicly as was my duty and people said
well this is what you get for sharing
bourbon with your wife
and here's the thing you know don't
victim blame me my wife usually
is a is an appreciator of wishes she'll
drink whiskey straight
that's what made this so gratuitous and
egregious
but no more that's not gonna happen
again okay
um so that was headline number one i
think the most important thing we'll go
to number two the the kyle rittenhouse
trial continues yesterday the
prosecution now this is the prosecution
okay remember that
they had richie mcginnis uh on on the
stand he's a daily caller reporter who
witnessed and filmed
what happened
that night there were not a lot of uh if
we were called during this in kenosha
and the riots all across the country in
2020
um
there were plenty of mainstream media
reporters on the scene
but uh they didn't they didn't see a lot
of the violence and chaos going on
because they were focused entirely on
the police
but richard mcginnis is one of the
reporters a real reporter on the scene
capturing what was happening
and um and he was a witness to what
happened with kyle rittenhouse and so he
was called in by the prosecution
and once again keep in mind this is the
prosecution's witness
and let's hear first i think we have a
couple of clips from him
um
he says first we'll play clip number
two where he talks about the sequence of
events
and what led up to it here it is
the sequence of the folks that were
involved in this running as we've seen
in many other videos is mr riddenhaus is
uh in front mr rosenbaum is running
after him and you are behind mr
rosenbaum is that fair to say
yes how far back from mr rosenbaum were
you as the through as as the
pursuit went through the car source
parking lot
um well it's hard to say because i kind
of caught up to them
i was running a bit faster and so
uh at the time initially i was probably
30 feet back when the first when
everybody first started running but then
by the time i arrived in the lot it was
15 feet
and you continued to be behind mr
rosenbaum at the time that the defendant
shot and killed him correct
um i did alter my trajectory a little
bit um when i
saw mr rittenhouse turn around and saw
mr rosenbaum
um plunging for the front portion of the
rifle
let me stop you there for a second yeah
i bet you i bet you want to stop him
there
so rosenbaum the victim quote-unquote
this is this is the uh
the man that the prosecution wants to
portray as the victim you have your own
witness on the stand saying that that
that the quote-unquote victim lunged for
the rifle of kyle rittenhouse
the the defense has not even presented
its case yet
and already the prosecution case has
fallen apart and it got worse from there
there was this moment which was a dagger
for the prosecution only they're
stabbing themselves okay this is them
stabbing themselves with the dagger
um
and here just watch this exchange it's
pretty incredible
and you've already established that
after the shooting mr rosenbaum never
says it worked correct
correct
you don't know
as you sit here today
what mr rosenbaum was thinking do
you you mean at the time in the shooting
yes
or at any point in his life i mean you
have no idea
what mr rosenbaum was ever thinking at
any point in his life you have never
been inside his head you never met him
before you don't i've never even i've
never exchanged words with him if that's
what your question is
so your interpretation of what he was
trying to do or what he was intending to
do or anything along those lines is
complete guesswork isn't it um
well he said thank you and then he
reached for the weapon
let's talk about that
my god that's um that is one of those
that's like one of those moments that
you see in a
in a trial in a tv show or a movie
um
you know the only the only thing you
would add in if this was in a movie then
that would have there have been gasps
and everything in the in the um
among the people there in the courtroom
to add a little bit of dramatic flair
into it but it is a gasp moment where
uh
your case just falls apart on the stand
so you have the quote-unquote victim
saying out loud
you know stating his
violent intentions out loud you have him
lunging for the weapon
[Music]
and i have to keep emphasizing that
these are the witnesses the prosecution
is bringing up
we haven't even heard from the defense's
witnesses yet
there's there's simply no case here
we have video evidence
which should put an end to it right
there because we can all see what
happened
certainly we had all along we had one of
the the shootings
on video
and you could very clearly see
that kyle rittenhouse is on the ground
and then he's got this mob of violent
people who are about to pounce on him
and then we had most of the other
shooting on the video and then we find
out later that the feds had the rest of
of of that video they didn't tell us
about it and we didn't see it until
right now
and on top of the video evidence we also
now have eyewitnesses the prosecution's
eyewitnesses the states eyewitnesses
who
uh are painting a picture of events that
entirely vindicates kyle written else
so when you see this and you listen to
what these witnesses have to say and you
watch the video
and you listen to the the state's
opening arguments and everything that
they presented
before the trial and during the trial so
far
and you see that they they
just have no case at all against this
guy
there is nothing there
now does that mean that written house
will actually walk
no because you never know what a jury
will do
and all it really takes is one antifa
sympathizer on that on that jury which
that could very easily be or more than
one
it only takes one blm sympathizer
there could very easily be one or more
than one
but uh
chances are
kyle riddenhaus certainly he deserves to
walk and i would say chances are that he
actually does
you know because it
this is so
incontrovertible it's so unavoidable the
facts are right there
as far as self-defense claims go
this is
about as
straightforward and simple as it gets
there are times when self-defense claims
are a little bit more complicated
there can obviously be gray areas
in situations like this but here there
is not
and that's why
all along
the people calling for kyle
rittenhouse's head
they're not really talking about the
shootings themselves
what you hear this is including the
prosecution's case
what what they keep going back to
and certainly what you hear online all
the time with the
outraged mob online saying kyle
rittenhouse should be in jail he should
be executed all these things people who
are otherwise are very much opposed to
supposedly
opposed to the death penalty but in this
case they'll make they'll make an
exception for kylo ren's because he's
white um
but what they keep saying is well he
shouldn't have been there to begin with
he he he crossed state lines
so what what difference does that make
so you cross state lines and now you
don't have a right to self-defense
anymore
so i live in tennessee if i go to
virginia and someone tries to kill me i
can't shoot them because i cross state
lines
coming by the way from people who don't
care about about lines they say that
lines are borders boundaries these are
imaginary boundaries
they say there's no significance to the
boundary separating the united states
from mexico
and anybody who lives
south of our of our southern border they
have every right to come here and enjoy
all of the freedoms and liberties and
entitlements that we enjoy as american
citizens including the right to vote
and now even we're going to be paying
off you know
giving out 450 000 checks for the buy
administration to these immigrants as
well so they'll say that's fine because
the border is imaginary
and yet the border separating a state
one state from another
is this
is this like this magical boundary
and once you cross it if you don't
belong to that state you have no right
to self-defense that's
the claim
well of course that's the claim for
people who have no principles whatsoever
they feel no need to be honest
they feel no obligation
to the truth whatsoever
um
and then as far as him oh he wasn't
supposed to be there
nobody was supposed to be there
like nothing
none of the events
in kenosha that night should have been
occurring
you had mobs of people burning down the
city none of that should have been
happening
so at worst
would say kyle rittenhouse
just like the other 50 000 people
didn't shouldn't have been there
rosenbaum the victim shouldn't have been
there
um
that's at worst like that's the worst
thing you could say about kyle
rittenhouse but i wouldn't even really
agree with that
because he worked in kenosha that was
that was his community as well
as someone who spent a lot of time there
he was helping to clean up graffiti
earlier in the day he actually cared
about the community
and he felt an obligation to go there
and
and do what law enforcement would not do
and when law enforcement refuses it to
do its job or is not allowed to do its
job or some combination of the two
then you're going to have some citizens
who feel called to step in and fill that
gap that's what call right now did
but whether he should or should not have
done that whether he should or should
not have been there whatever that means
he still has a basic right to
self-defense
and that's very clear so then you have
to start asking yourself
considering that there's no case at all
here
and the state knows that they have no
case
okay they're not crazy they know there's
no case here
there's a reason why they had to bring
richie mcginnis up because they don't
have anybody else
so then you really have to ask what what
what are they trying to achieve here
you have to start asking yourself
do they want more riots is that what
this is about
because you're going to get them
once he's exonerated which which he
probably will be
you're going to have mass riots again in
kenosha
antifa and blm they've already promised
that they've stated that ahead of time
if you don't convict this guy we're
going to riot
they are trying to coax a guilty verdict
just like they did
with derek chovin by threatening
violence and implicitly threatening it
against the jurors as well if they don't
get what they want
implicitly and also in some cases
explicitly
so is that the point in the end the the
powers that be here do they do they want
more riots and more chaos in the streets
you really have to start wondering about
that
i mean you could also theorize the other
way and say that they well they're
trying to appease the mob and that's the
reason they arrested and charged them to
begin with
but they would also have to know that
this appeasement is very temporary
i mean there would have been additional
rioting had they never charged him at
all
but that would have all happened back
last summer when when they were rioting
anyway
so they could have said right then look
there's no case here this is
self-defense we're not going to charge
him
uh the left would have been very upset
about it there would have been
you know
it would it would have put some more
literal fuel on the fire but it's a fire
that was already burning at that point
and we would have all long since moved
on by now
now what you've guaranteed once he's
exonerated is that you're going to have
mass rioting
along the lines of what we saw last
summer if not worse
is that the intention is that what they
actually want
again you have to you have to really
wonder
okay let's move on to this we keep
hearing that critical race theory isn't
being taught in schools this is what we
heard in virginia this is the case that
terry mcauliffe makes this is what the
media keeps saying critical race theory
they sometimes sometimes they say it
doesn't exist it's a it's a boogeyman
invented
uh by the right
which is which is a problem because
there have been actual books written
with critical race theory in the title
by the people who came up with this
theory and are promoting it
but even if it exists what we're told is
it's not taught in schools
and the thing is
that's true
in a certain way
it's true but it's sometimes you can lie
while telling the truth
you can tell the truth in a way that is
intentionally misleading and here we
have a public school teacher in indiana
explaining what it really means when
they say the critical race theory isn't
taught in schools let's listen to that
i'm the science coach in admin in the
largest public school district in
indiana i'm in dozens of classrooms a
week so i see exactly what we're
teaching our students when we tell you
that schools aren't teaching critical
race theory that it's nowhere in our
standards that's misdirection we don't
have the quotes and theories as state
standards per se
we do have critical race theory in how
we teach we tell our teachers to treat
students differently based on color we
tell our students that every problem is
a result of white men and that
everything western civilization built as
racist capitalism as a tool of white
supremacy those are straight out of
kimberley crenshaw's main points
verbatim in critical race theory the
writings that formed the movement
this is in math history science english
the arts and it's not slowing down if
students of color have lower reading
scores it's because of inequity
therefore we take from the white
students and give to the color students
that's richard delgado straight out of
crt in introduction
all teaching is political with reality
and facts taking the back seat that's dr
gloria lads and billings who outlined
how she saw critical race theory fleshed
out in public schools in 1995.
when schools tell you that we aren't
teaching critical race theory it means
one thing go away and look into our
affairs no further it isn't about
transparency it isn't about cultural
relevance it's race essentialism painted
to look like the district cares about
students of color we call it anti-racism
so you feel bad if you disagree with our
segregationist pedagogy it's taking
advantage of kids vulnerability and
parents inactivity to preen over social
snake oil schemes designed to create
division
parents when we tell you critical race
theory isn't taught in our schools we're
lying keep looking
well he lays it out right there um and
that's
like it's just like if if uh if they
claim you know when we say that
the public schools are leftist and that
there's leftism you know in the broadest
sense in the public school system
well they could say well we don't teach
leftism look at our curriculum nowhere
does it say the term leftist or leftism
oh you silly parents why you think your
kid is going to a leftism 101 class
that's obviously not what's happening in
fact i wouldn't object to that
necessarily i mean in theory i wouldn't
object to that
having a class on the subject of modern
day leftism i wouldn't even necessarily
in theory object to a class on critical
race theory because i think it is
something that unfortunately our kids
need to know about now i wouldn't trust
the average public school teacher to
teach it
but kids are going to get to a certain
age where you do have to teach them
about this
it's a good thing to teach them about it
about the subject
just like they should learn about
marxism and communism
you want them to learn about those
things
it's the people who are
trying to indoctrinate kids into these
worldviews
that don't want the kids taught about
the worldview
and that should tell you what you need
to know
but that's not what's happening so
treating
treating these things as a subject and
saying here's this
world view that exists here's this idea
this system of thought
uh here's what it what it teaches
there you go presenting the information
that could be a good
thing i mean all of the most insidious
world views
the wider spread that they are the more
that i think we need to uh
it's good for us to know what they are
and be taught about them
but that's not what's happening what's
happening is much much worse than that
as the teacher just explained
instead it's the assumptions of critical
race theory are embedded
into everything the kids are taught
so this is a big
you know this is a this is a red herring
this is misdirection
it's the slight of hand trick where they
you know they hand you the curriculum
and they say see look at the curriculum
you'll see nowhere on this curriculum
does it say critical race theory yeah
it's not being taught
what they fail to mention is that in
every single one of those subjects on
that curriculum
all of those subjects are built around
and upon these the assumptions of
critical race theory
that white people are inherently racist
that um all of our historical
ills and all the historical evils are
all the result of
of white people and western expansion
um that it's you know it's not even
possible to be racist against
white people because racism equals
is whatever prejudice plus power
kids are taught all of that where else
are they getting this stuff from
yeah they're getting it from the media
they're getting it from
social media from the internet but um
you're getting it from a lot of places
but they're certainly getting it from
the schools
as well
and the fact that they are told these
things
and yet are not told
that this is critical race theory that's
precisely the problem
again i would have no i think i would
have no problem in theory
with a kid being told hey there's this
thing called critical race theory and
according to critical race theory what
critical race theory teaches
is that if you're white you're
inherently racist
and that if a black person comes up to
you
and says they hate you because you're
white
you are not a victim of racism because
they can't be racist against you
that's what critical race theory teaches
that's a good thing for people to be
told because then they can say oh well
okay well that so that's a theory i
don't ascribe to it sounds like a pretty
horrible theory
remember the word theory you know
it's also important to remember
the word theory when used in a
scientific context it doesn't just mean
a you know a hypothesis or a guess
a theory uh like the the quote-unquote
theory of gravity right
it's a system
for explaining
what you see in the physical world
that's what a theory is in science
uh we talk about the theory of evolution
right or you know
the germ theory of disease it's a system
for explaining and understanding what
you're observing in the physical world
critical race theory
positions itself as that kind as a
theory in that way it's a system
of explaining and understanding what we
not what we see in the physical world
but what we what we see in human society
but it's a bad system
it's a it's an evil system
it's a sinister system
all right
what else we got here so the word milk
was trending on twitter yesterday if you
spend any time on twitter if you make
that mistake then you may have noticed
that that the word milk was trending
and you know you click on it come to
find out it's because a bunch of
media people a bunch of blue checks on
twitter democrats are laughing
hysterically about this segment on cnn
and it's one of the only times you'll
see real reporting on cnn
and of course the left hated this they
were mad about it the one occasion in
the last year of cnn doing real
reporting left they were not fans of it
and this features a large family that
buys 12 gallons of milk a week
and they're talking about how as a large
family
that where they have to buy lots of
groceries
how inflation has affected them
but the left they thought this was
hilarious you know lots of dunking on
this lots of verified media people
finding it very funny who drinks 12
gallons of milk lol
well let's some people do some families
do and uh just like this family let's
watch
and the other thing that inflation is
affecting right now is food prices these
are things that you have to buy so i
went to canada texas to go shopping with
a family to talk about what this
actually means to live in america right
now
[Music]
all right let's go tackle this what does
inflation mean for american families
this is the story of the statler's
weekly shop good to see you guys good to
see you
we have two biological kids and then my
wife and i have a big heart for adoption
so we adopted a sibling group of
two
then three then one and then we have a
a kid living with us right now who's uh
kind of a foster situation
it feels like money isn't going as far
as it used to okay
let's see what we can do
i think probably in june it was about a
dollar was worth a dollar so now that
dollar is worth about 70 cents all right
now we're moving on to dairy which is
right there
we started seeing everything going up
grocery prices went up gallon of milk
was 1.99 now it's 279. well when you buy
12 gallons a week times four weeks you
know you're that's a lot of money that's
what i'm talking about thanks brother
yeah um
almost everything you need to know about
the modern left can be summed up in the
reaction to that report which again was
one of it was it was outrage at cnn for
reporting on this at all
and also mockery of this family for
drinking 12 gallons of milk a week and
finding it very very funny and hilarious
um and because these are all childless
people or they come from or you know
they were they were
growing up they were single children
and um
you know what one child homes and now
they don't have any children and so
what it's like to have a big family it's
totally foreign and alien to them
they look at i come from a relatively
large family i've got five brothers and
sisters
which there was a time in uh western
civilization where that wouldn't even
qualify as a big family but now it now
it is now you're like a circus you're
like a circus act if you have that many
kids in your family um i'm almost at
that level now we only have four kids
and we go places and and people look at
us and say wow all those kids really got
your hands full i can't believe
it's four kids what are you talking
about this is not
one of you know what my sister has ten
kids okay this is in my in my family
this is nothing we're we're starter
level
in terms of the size of the family but
that's how they see big families i see
big families as uh as a funny
sideshow act
and they look on it with a mixture of
mockery and also
disgust
and so to them
the trials and tribulations
of
you know
a big family
it's it's funny it's it's also
irrelevant
to their lives
yeah that that adds up
i mean this is also a family how did
they how did they end up with nine kids
well they had you know two or three kids
of their own and then they adopted kids
and you know they not only that they
adopted whole you know families of kids
rather than rather than breaking up
uh siblings which is what can happen the
adoption system is very tragic
they brought in all the siblings
so you would think
i guess you wouldn't think
but what ought to
you know what we ought to have is
immense amount of respect for that
and so
yeah when you've got a large family and
you're not rich
the fact that
prices on things like milk have been
skyrocketing
that can be that can be devastating
because you have to buy food
that's an actual need
and yeah anyone who actually has
a kid or certainly more than one kid
knows that they can go through a lot of
milk i mean even with forecast i'm not
sure how much milk we go through but
it's it's a lot more than you would
think
um
kids just run through that stuff they
drink a lot of milk you've got yeah they
eat a lot of cereal
but to the left it's all quite funny
and uh and now and now what they've
decided what they're they're treating
the inflation story as some sort of like
conspiracy theory and so they were
online yesterday trying to debunk the
idea that there's inflation
but once again if you're a real person
and you go shopping and you go to the
grocery store
especially if you're a middle-class
family
and the budget's pretty tight
there is no escaping the reality here
i'm able to hide from it a little bit
because my wife
does most of the grocery shopping
but even before this inflation kicked in
any time i was enlisted to go do the
grocery shopping
it's it's all it's always a little bit
of a shock to the system to see how
expensive all this stuff actually is
and now even more so
all right
we will uh jump ahead now into our
comment section
nick burden says is there a way i could
support the daily wire without
purchasing a subscription i fully
believe in what the dw is doing last
year i was a little bit of a leftist but
thanks to matt and ben
um i'm converted i want to support the
dw though i don't think i'd ever
actually use a subscription well you can
send me cash directly just put it in an
envelope and send it right to me
um no just kidding don't do that but get
just get the subscription that's what
you can do all right be a part be a team
player
um
a body in progress says matt you
acknowledge that humanity needs to see
and interact with each other then you
denounce speaking out loud to another
human being on the phone in favor of
texting
i much prefer actually talking to
someone over texting him or her
okay but this is not
you know it's not like talking on the
phone is some ancient traditional form
of communication
i think the phone is part of this
severing of human connections
it's part of the problem it began this
process
and it's it's not the same for me i
don't know
you either you either understand it or
you don't
and there are some people who they love
talking on the phone
i cannot understand that at all
but i can tell you i am not alone and
for people like me talking on the phone
i don't know how else to put it other
than it is it is physically almost
painful to talk on the phone to somebody
and it's hard to explain exactly why i
think i i explained it a little bit
yesterday
because it's it's conversation
devoid of
body language you know a lot of the you
know they say whatever percent just 70
80 90 of human communication is through
body language and others and other
nonverbal signals we send to each other
well you're taking that out of it
completely
and yet still trying to have a
conversation at least through text
message you're just you're sending a
message you have a point you want to
make you send it and that's it
but trying to carry on a conversation
without any of those other signals
is for me deeply uncomfortable
and it adds a certain sort of intensity
to it and then there's also the problem
of as i said
there's no room for pauses and if you
think about it when you're sitting like
in your living room with somebody
or like when i was in the kitchen with
my wife last night talking to her
until she traumatized me by wasting the
whiskey you know you're you're talking
and then and then there's a
little bit of a pause and then you talk
some more and that's okay but with a
phone conversation you're not allowed to
do that and that's the problem
all right um
alina says matt i was not here when spg
started what happened
explaining this new movement i'm
involved into my other teenage friends
is interesting
but you don't explain it that's the
first rule of the movement
this is not like fight club where first
world fight club is you don't talk about
fight club we talk about the sweet baby
gang we talk about it all the time and
i'm told that i talk about it too much
we just don't talk about its origins
that's what we don't do
as far as anyone is concerned the sweet
baby gang has always been here
and we'll always be here that's the
mythology that we're building okay
um
lucky says can matt make a daily
cancellation for people who can't
parallel park i don't think it's as
vital as merging i just need a better
explanation than the one from my parents
you know yeah parallel parking
clearly there are so many bad drivers
out there and much of driving is very
simple i mean you do it on much of what
you do when you're driving you're doing
unconsciously that's how simple and easy
it is and most people in the world are
not able to even do that parallel
parking actually involves conscious
engagement and it's a little bit more
complicated
so if the average person can't handle
something like merging or just driving
in one lane on the highway
um
how much how much worse is it going to
be when they try to parallel park so
that's true a lot of most people can't
parallel park
um i am the fantastic parallel parker i
take
great pride in that
um
any ti even though i even though i've
successfully parallel parked many times
every time i do i have to brag to my
wife about it you know that's just
that's part of the deal it's part of
being a man um
but it's also not
i don't really care if you're not a good
parallel parker
that that doesn't bother me you're not
going to kill anybody from doing it the
wrong way
and if you're not comfortable with it
then just don't parallel park usually
you can find some other parking
situation and you can kind of avoid it
especially if you don't live in the city
if you don't live in the city you can go
your whole life and never have to
parallel park
whereas merging is something that if you
drive you have to do
probably every day
and if you do it wrong this is more than
a fender bender situation you're gonna
kill somebody
and that's why that should be but i
remember when i don't know if this is
how it still works when i took the
driving exam
the
the grand finale of the driving exam the
actual physical driving exam where
you're sitting in there with the person
with the clipboard
um and it seems i don't do they still do
driving exams
the evidence on the road would seem to
indicate that they don't
but when i was
you know 16 you take the driving exam
and parallel parking was the grand
finale it was the main thing you had to
execute
on the driving exam they had to make
sure you could do a three-point turn
that you knew how to stop at a stop sign
and uh and then can you parallel park
and that's it that's all they did
no take that out of it again you could
go your whole life and never have to do
it depending on where you live
take that out of it and put merging
in the driving exam
um although that is maybe somewhere
where maybe you do the merging in a
virtual reality metaverse situation uh
so that you know we're not losing
driving instructors left and right
to car accidents
let's see what else do we got
um
steve says come on man cherry that's so
last decade let's go orange for kool-aid
or could i get behind grape i suppose
the gray rooster says grape is the best
kool-aid flavor there's no denying this
universal absolute truth
another guy says please grant unto us
thy loving cherry kool-aid holy sweet
father
lots of comments giving me your favorite
kool-aid flavor just want to clarify one
thing you guys do realize what i was
inferring is that i'm going to be
poisoning
snow last winter
uh yeah they effectively shut down in
fact what they did when we got a little
bit of snow
is uh this is the other thing i had this
this is when i first became acquainted
with nashville driving because i got
here you know only a couple months
before we got that i guess what is a
once in a generation kind of ice
snowstorm where it's snowed for a week
and the nashville strategy
with snow removal
is to not do it and so what they say
here is if you get snow on on the
highway if you get it on your road
then um that's it you just have snow and
that's they're going to wait for the sun
to take care of it even if it takes two
weeks
but other than that
other than everything that happens on
the road i do love it here at nashville
just to clarify now as you may or may
not be aware
the daily wire filed a lawsuit against
the federal government yesterday we
talked about that on the show why
because in an authoritarian
anti-american move the biden
administration has ordered that large
employers must require their employees
to be vaccinated
against covenanting or submit to regular
testing daily wires lawsuit was filed by
the dillon law group and alliance
defending freedom in the u.s court of
appeals in the sixth circuit the lawsuit
alleges that the bind administration
lacks constitutional and statutory
authority to issue the employer mandate
and that the mandate failed to meet the
requirements for issuing a rule taking
effect immediately about the normal
process of considering public comments
this mandate is absolutely
unconstitutional and we're not standing
for it here at the daily wire we're not
going to simply complain about it but
then go along with it
because then the complaints mean nothing
at all our employees deserve to keep
their medical history private have
autonomy over their own bodies and honor
any of their religious beliefs we stand
with our employees rights as we do
with the rights of every single american
the buying administration has warned
that any companies that do not comply
with this federal overreach could be
fined as much as 136 thousand dollars
per violation
which is why we need your help if you're
not a member yet please consider joining
us today if you um go to dailywire.com
subscribe right now enter code do not
comply at checkout you'll receive 25 off
your membership you can be part of the
team and you can help us in our fight
against this unconstitutional mandate
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so dave portnoy who's the founder of bar
stool sports was you might say destined
for a metoo movement uh moment rather
he's a single man he's famous wealthy
most crucially
not a leftist and i'm not sure what his
political philosophy is or if he has one
but it's clear at least that he's far
from woke by the current standard um and
it's likely this last fact that
compelled julia black who's a reporter
for business insider to embark on a
quest to uncover a portnoy sex assault
scandal one way or another
now previous attempts had been made to
cancel portnoy for jokes he'd said in
years past before jokes became illegal
and other you know commons and things
that he made
but those canceled campaigns were easily
swatted away those sorts of cancellings
can always be diffused if the target has
any semblance of a spine a modicum of
self-respect
um for those sorts of things you could
always just ignore them refuse to bend
to them and you'll be fine
but a metoo
thing a me too onslaught is a different
beast entirely
that's why julia black spent as she
admits herself eight months
trying to
organize what
for dave portnoy
as it turns out
it would seem
that there wasn't really a portnoy sex
assault scandal to be uncovered
much to the chagrin of julia black and
business insider
based on the story portnoy has never
raped anyone you know he's never raped
anyone but if the allegations are true
he has had at least a few weird and
uncomfortable liaisons that's enough to
justify a 4 000 word expose
with a scary sounding headline the
headline is i was literally screaming in
pain young women say they met bar stool
sports founder dave portnoy for sex and
it turned violent and humiliating
now if you want to read the rest you
have to become a business insider
subscriber
but don't worry senior politics reporter
grace panetta tweeted hours after the
article was published the business
insider is offering a great discount on
premium subscriptions
pay now and you can read all about the
dave portnoy allegations
dave portnoy is a dangerous sex criminal
become a subscriber and read more about
it
of course if you don't want to pay you
can share the article anyway with its
screaming headline and that'll do just
fine as well lots of people did that
now personally i wasn't interested in
either of those options so i accessed
the article without paying i have my
ways and promptly discovered that it is
one of the more transparent hit pieces
that we've seen published on the
internet in quite some time
it begins with a story of madison 20
years old
who messaged portnoy on instagram last
summer and some of the details here are
getting a little bit graphic warning you
ahead of time
uh but it's necessary to understand the
story here
so they quickly began talking about sex
and she was happy to reveal
that she has a quote rape fantasy where
i don't have any control of what's going
on
unquote
but madison did make sure to stipulate
that she has to be pretty comfortable
with a guy before she'll act out her
rape fantasies with him and shortly
after this exchange she boarded a flight
to come visit portnoy at his mansion in
nantucket
now madison made it to his house in the
afternoon um she complains that portnoy
was boring and grumpy
now it's not often that a victim takes
the time to lodge these kinds of
complaints in the case of an actual
sexual assault
the assailant's grumpiness
is hardly worth mentioning so the fact
that those details are added already
makes you a little bit suspicious
after dinner having known portnoy in
person for about three hours she began
performing oral sex on him he filmed it
uh she did not object now she says now
that she didn't want him to film it but
she was too scared to tell him to stop
that's when things escalated she says
quoting now from the article says from
there things escalated until as madison
put it
quote i felt like i was just a human sex
doll
two days later madison texted a close
friend quote it was so rough that i felt
like i was being raped he videotaped me
and spit in my mouth and choked me so
hard i couldn't breathe she wrote in
messages viewed by insider and it hurt
and i was literally screaming in pain
she recalled crying and shouting too
much too much it hurts it was so painful
madison said i kept trying to get away
and he was like stop running away from
me stop running away from me
but portnoy she said just went harder
now madison's flight home wasn't until
two days later so she slept on portnoy's
couch both nights and they didn't have
sex again
now madison doesn't claim that she
doesn't use the word sexually assaulted
she doesn't claim that she was raped
only that the sex was violent and
humiliating
though it would seem by her own
admission
that's exactly what she got on the plane
and flew to portnoy's house for
telling him about her rape fantasy
next there's a story of 19 year old
allison who went to portnoy's house to
hook up here's how she recounts the
events that followed quote
alison recalled sitting by the pool
portnoy offered her watermelon in water
he asked her which school she went to
and which grade she was in allison
recalled that then she said he got up to
go inside and i was like okay i'll go in
with you and he was like i didn't know
it would be that easy he landed leaned
in and started kissing me and i didn't
know what to do at that point she added
and he went upstairs and he was really
aggressive and i didn't know how to do i
didn't know what to do and we had sex
and that was it and he kicked me out
allison said her memories were fuzzy
because of her emotional distress
surrounding the event
but uh like madison she said portnoy
choked her
and then she goes into some other
details and she says uh
that allison does not describe what
happened to her sexual assault this is
an important point but she was still
deeply disturbed by the experience quote
i just felt very preyed on she said
now the final quote-unquote victim
chronicled in the piece is instagram
influencer ava louise who never had any
physical contact with the bar stool ceo
but did message him with a few years ago
when she was 19. she told him that she
quote wanted to be famous so bad
didn't end up meeting him in person but
she told business insider that quote i
probably would have let dave portnoy do
whatever the hell he wanted to me
because i'm like oh my god it's dave
portnoy
and she's now come to believe though
that portnoy was predatory for messaging
with her
so
uh we're left we're left with
a handful of stories selected after
reporter reached out apparently to
dozens of women portnoy had interacted
with looking for the juiciest gossip she
could find
and all these stories from women with
fuzzy memories who don't allege assault
don't use that word
and who engaged apparently in consensual
sex
one of these women according to her own
testimony boarded a plane and flew to
his house after telling him about her
rape fantasies
she then stayed at his house for two
days after the encounter that she now
claims traumatized her
as for that woman madison portnoy claims
that not only did she never tell him to
stop but that she never expressed any
discomfort or awkwardness at all
until he read about it for the first
time in business insider here's his
statement about it
at no point was it not 100 consensual at
no point did she ask me to stop at no
point did either of us think something
unseemly happened there was no weirdness
after it was totally fine normal
interaction sexual
100 consensual my lawyers like you don't
don't you know make these blankets i'm
telling you now her version of events is
not true on our hookup just not true
neither of us were like oh you shouldn't
be doing it it was 100 million percent
consensual what's going on her brain i
have no idea her actions outward all 100
normal wasn't alarmed never thought
about it now after we hooked up we're
hanging out more and it just became one
of those situations where
we just agreed basically on everything
from you know is it raining or sunny out
is is this oil and vinegar two people
who did not get along did not see the
world the same way and that is why she
slept on the couch i do believe my
recollection is she was still interested
in hooking up and i'm like it's this
just isn't working like we don't get
along um
flew back i never talked to her again i
never knew she had any issue it's the
first i heard of it and frankly was
stunned to read and hear about it
so he goes on actually for a while
addressing all the allegations and he
denies
them i mean he doesn't deny that he had
sexual interactions with these women but
he denies that the story that it went
exactly as they described
you have to ask yourself whose story
fits the facts better well one of the
facts here is that madison stayed at his
house
for two days after the fact
so you would think that if she was
trying to
literally run away from
a rapist
that she wouldn't then stay at the house
even if your flight is a few days
removed maybe you would leave and go to
a hotel or something or really anything
other than state house
but as always with a metoo witch hunt
the women involved in these interactions
are treated
as though they have no agency or
willpower of their own i mean these are
all adults all eager and willing
participants in the sexual act in at
least one case the woman not only
participated but initiated
it's not victim blaming to suggest that
a woman who goes to a man's house for
sex then has sex then continues to stay
at the house after the sex
bears at least equal responsibility for
the emotional or psychological toll that
it takes on the participants
and i say that even though i don't deny
that there is a toll
i don't even balk at a word like trauma
being used to describe the emotional
aftermath
with something like this
they all say that they felt used and
degraded like they were treated as mere
sex dolls
i have no doubt that there's truth to
that assessment
but none of that equates to rape
and this is also the empty and grim
reality
of hookup culture
both partners use each other
a woman with rape fantasies quote
unquote has gotten so used to this sort
of transactional sex dehumanizing and
degrading on both sides
that she now orients her sex life around
it she's fetishized her own degradation
the participants in hook-up culture make
a game of their own self-abasement
and they wake up in the morning
oftentimes feeling exploited and exposed
because that's exactly what happened
and and worse
if you're participating consensually in
hookup culture
you are inviting your own exploitation
pursuing it
again on both sides men and women
now people these days have no language
to describe or understand their feelings
having rejected sexual morality in
principle
and so they conclude that somehow their
consent must have been violated
even if they even if it's an act that
they agreed to participate in
they conclude that they
had their consent violated they say well
i don't feel good
after the fact so i must not have chosen
to do this
but they did choose it and that's the
whole tragedy of hookup culture
people choose what ultimately makes them
miserable and unfulfilled
i mean you talk to a man
on
uh
instagram or whatever
and he flies you to his house to have
sex with him
and you say you feel like a sex doll
well yes
i'm sure you did feel that way
and i'm sure it's horrible to feel that
way
but that's what hookup culture is
the answer to this problem
is not me too
but marriage
the answer to the problem
is
to take the sexual act
and engage in it
with someone who you love and are
devoted to
and who you trust
someone who cares about you
who knows your name and a lot more than
your name
that's the answer to much of what
um
metoo has brought to bear
and
much of the dysfunction that we see in
our society today
and the answer is certainly not hit
pieces like the one in business insider
the publication which is today in the
end we come back around to uh cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day and a great weekend
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pablo
the show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin